[Música]
en el 2014 lima fue declarada por la
organización mundial de la salud como en
la ciudad con el aire más contaminado de
latinoamérica y esto se debió
principalmente a las emisiones de gases
de escape del parque automotor el cual
es alimentado con combustibles que no
necesariamente son de la mejor calidad
este problema general ha generado la
muerte de más de 5000 personas solamente
en lima y se lleva la vida de cientos de
miles alrededor del mundo cada año pero
cómo se forman estos gases de escape
bueno los motores de hoy en día
funcionan principalmente a gasolina oa
dice el motor queme el combustible para
transformar su energía en movimiento
pero no pensaría de que la gasolina se
aprovecha al 100% al ingresar al motor
pero nada está más lejos de eso ya que
el combustible por lo general no se
quema completamente dentro del motor y
generando sus productos como el humo el
monóxido de carbono y restos de gasolina
que entraron al motor no se quemaron y
salieron por el escape
de esta forma adicionalmente
desperdiciar mucha energía
el motor libera gases contaminantes en
el medio ambiente el humo está
conformado por cientos de compuestos
tóxicos y cancerígenos que acompañan a
finas partículas de carbón negro que son
fácilmente inhaladas el monóxido de
carbono al ser inhalado impide que la
sangre transporte oxígeno pudiendo
generar daños al sistema cardíaco y
nervioso y los restos de gasolina y
diésel que salieron al escape y son
respirados por las personas pues les
pueden generar daños en los pulmones y
picor en los ojos por simple exposición
esto es un problema que nos afecta como
ciudadanos a pie quien no ha visto el
humo salir por los buses de de
transporte público de nuestra ciudad aun
así el uso de maquinarias ha ayudado a
que la humanidad progrese quien se
imagina un mundo moderno sin vehículos
sin camiones sin buses o sin barcos pero
somos conscientes de que esto puede
generar un gran problema medioambiental
y de salud pública y lo peor de todo es
que yo era parte de ese gran problema
cuando era estudiante universitario mi
padre me regaló un carro antiguo este al
arrancar cada mañana votaba una gran
nube de humo negro la cual se iba
transformando en un sutil olor a
gasolina al ir calentando esto me hacía
sentir muy mal ya que mi familia
respiraba cada mañana eso haces
contaminantes y como era un motor
sumamente contaminante e ineficiente el
excesivo consumo de combustible
afectaba mi economía de estudiante de
tercer año de universidad decidido dije
se acabó me compro un carro nuevo
revise mis ahorros y me di cuenta que no
me alcanzaba ni para las llantas
resignado y con frustración me di cuenta
que realmente si es que vendía mi carro
del nuevo dueño seguiría contaminando
igual o más que yo y con mayor
frustración aún me di cuenta como es en
este escenario podría ser replicado
cientos de millones de veces en muchos
usuarios de vehículos alrededor del
mundo estudiaba ingeniería y debía
realizar una tesis y es por eso que dije
por qué no investigar para desarrollar
algo que le ponga fin a la contaminación
de mi carro investigue durante meses
pasado mucho tiempo en el laboratorio y
luego de mucho prototipar diseñó un
dispositivo que aceleraba la combustión
de mi motor
volviéndolo casi tan eficiente como el
de un motor moderno el humo desapareció
creí tener en mis manos una gran
tecnología un buen producto con el cual
ayudar a miles de personas a dejar de
contaminar como lo habían logrado
pero este prototipo en vehículos
antiguos con excelentes resultados
pero en vehículos modernos los
resultados no fueron los mismos las
nuevas tecnologías de motores modernos
hacían de que este prototipo no sea
compatible y que no generase ese cambio
en la combustión con frustración me di
cuenta de que el potencial de mercado
para mi prototipo se achicaba muchísimo
y de que peor aún es esa reducción de
emisiones que yo quería llevar al mundo
se había frustrada pero reflexionando
más me di cuenta de que en poco tiempo
había logrado crear algo muy efectivo
para cierto tipo de vehículos y que si
es que seguía investigando sería tan
sólo cuestión de tiempo en lograr crear
algo que sea bueno tanto para motores
antiguos como para motores modernos debo
ser sincero me tomo muchos meses y si es
que hubiese trabajado solo quizás no
hubiese prosperado y es así que conocí a
darío el estudiado a química pura y era
muy bueno en el laboratorio
adicionalmente había trabajado casi toda
su vida en la empresa de transporte de
su familia sabía de química y de motores
darío fue mi colega en las prácticas que
realicé en el área de investigación de
la universidad
y al terminar nuestro contrato le
comenté sobre el proyecto el cual le
entusiasmó tanto como a mí y de ese
entonces fuimos socios
darío investigamos mucho más y
descubrimos que había un gran problema
que afectaba tanto a motores antiguos
como modernos y este problema tenía
poquísimas soluciones este problema es
las bacterias que crecen dentro del
combustible
ya los he visto fruncir el ceño dirán
bacterias en la gasolina microbios en el
diésel como seres es posible permiten
explicarle los combustibles
hidrocarburos son en términos muy
generales compuestos orgánicos para que
tengan una idea un compuesto orgánico
bastante más cotidiano es la leche qué
pasa si es que dejo un vaso de leche
sobre una mesa durante una semana se
pudre no pues lo mismo pasa con la
gasolina y el diésel antes de que los
combustibles lleguen a sus carros estos
han sido almacenados en la refinería
luego transportados en camiones para
luego pasar algunos días en el grifo
hasta que son surtidos a sus vehículos
donde pasan algunas semanas hasta que
son utilizados este escenario genera una
putrefacción lenta del combustible en
pocas palabras se va degradando
el combustible contiene bacterias que
particularmente en este caso se
alimentan de la misma gasolina y del
dice estas bacterias no tienen bocas
como nosotros sino que tienen una
membrana a través de la cual absorben
parte de las moléculas de la gasolina y
del dicen para alimentarse crecer y
reproducirse tradicionalmente luego de
alimentarse liberan sus productos o
desechos los cuales son principalmente
ácidos que pueden corroer a las partes
metálicas del motor pero cómo afecta de
forma práctica las bacterias al
funcionamiento del vehículo bueno todo
empieza en el tanque de combustible
donde las bacterias están rodeadas de
alimentos cómodas en un entorno cálido y
donde si llegan a reproducirse en exceso
pues pueden obstruir la bomba que
impulsa la gasolina o el diesel hacia el
motor luego el combustible pasa por un
filtro este filtro tiene por fin retener
partículas o sedimentos que puedan
afectar al motor éste retiene tan sólo
una parte de las bacterias ya que
algunas de ellas
tan chiquititas que lo pasan en las que
son retenidas siguen reproduciéndose
alimentándose dentro de él degradando
también el combustible por eso si es que
abrimos un filtro de combustible usado
podemos ver que tiene una una apariencia
moss luego el combustible sigue fluyendo
y las bacterias pueden llegar hacia los
inyectores estos inyectores tienen la
función de dosificar y atomizar el
combustible esta atomización es muy
similar a la pulverización que se genera
con el perfume cuando apretamos la
cabeza del frasco la formación de
pequeñas gotitas asegura un óptimo
funcionamiento del motor y de estas
bacterias pueden obstruir total o
parcialmente los inyectores
entorpeciendo su funcionamiento y
finalmente pues un combustible lleno de
bacterias no se va a quemar de manera
eficiente como lo haría un combustible
puro en pocas palabras las bacterias se
afectan todo el sistema de combustible
afectando su eficiencia su confiabilidad
y generando
las emisiones cuando dijimos eureka este
es el problema que tenemos que atacar
pusimos manos a la obra empezamos a leer
cómo funcionan estas bacterias y a
prototipar distintas soluciones y
logramos solucionar este problema
creando una tecnología que destruye
las bacterias contenidas en el
combustible tan sólo por entrar en
contacto con él pero como lo queramos
llegamos a desarrollar un catalizador un
material que inhibe el proceso mediante
el cual las bacterias se alimentan y más
bien lo invierte haciendo que éstas en
vez de alimentarse se mueran digamos que
si antes la bacteria estaba un entorno
similar al caribe cálidas rodeadas de
alimento reproduciéndose bastante
alegremente ahora al ingresar nuestro
catalizador al combustible pasamos de un
entorno similar al caribe a uno similar
al polo norte donde las bacterias se
encuentran sumamente incómodas pierden
la habilidad de alimentarse y pues
pero vamos es esta tecnología en una
muestra de dice podrido la cual se fue
purificando con el paso de unas horas
aquí podemos ver como un combustible
podrido pasó a estar tan puro como para
usarse eficientemente en un motor
este es el prototipo lo instalamos en el
carro petrolero de darío y el humo se
redujo en 80%
le tocaba pasar revisión técnica y es
así que lo llevamos los técnicos se
sorprendieron pensaron que la máquina de
análisis de gases se había malogrado
como un carro de 10 años de antigüedad
puede contaminar menos que un carro
nuevo lo probamos en algunos carros de
unos amigos y nos reportaban que el
gasto se había reducido entre 8 a 20 por
ciento mientras recuperaban en la
aceleración
parece entonces ya nos habían
entrevistado en algunos medios y las
empresas automotrices nos invitaban a
exponer el producto y el proyecto
sugerentes
el gerente general entusiasmado dijo yo
quiero este producto en mi negocio me va
a traer más ventas el gerente técnico
entusiasmadísimo este producto me
soluciona problemas mis motores van a
ser más confiables y va a tener mejores
prestaciones pero el gerente de
marketing este producto parece un rulero
es feo no tiene marca ni empaque no da
que golpe tan duro estar a punto de ver
nuestro nuestro producto en el mercado y
recibir un frenazo de esa manera pero
darío yo estábamos acostumbrados así que
seguimos adelante nos tomó algo de
tiempo pero logramos crear un diseño que
denotaba el nivel tecnológico de nuestra
innovación y como somos más científicos
que diseñadores en el camino
multiplicamos por 14 la efectividad de
destrucción de bacterias mientras
reducimos el peso por la mitad hoy en
día este producto se ve así
un vehículo en promedio requiere tres
unidades de este catalizador para
eliminar las bacterias a un ritmo tal de
que el gasto en combustible se reducen
hasta 20 por ciento reduciendo a su vez
las emisiones contaminantes en 90 por
ciento pero se acuerdan de ese problema
que les comenté en las ciudades de las
emisiones tóxicas que afectan a la
población pues ahora imagínense una mina
subterránea donde las maquinarias pues
están el emanando emisiones de humo y de
monóxido carbono donde están confinadas
en un túnel subterráneo y pues donde los
trabajadores respiran estos gas con
darío dijimos tenemos que hacer algo y
regresamos al laboratorio y diseñamos un
sistema algo más complejo compatible con
vehículos con camiones ligeros y con
maquinaria minera y lo llevamos a la
mina y lo probamos no ven hasta el 90%
menos humo y hasta 90% menos monóxido de
carbono y hoy en día nos llena de
orgullo regresar a las minas
los técnicos agradeciendo nos gracias
por su invento ingeniero ya no me pica
en los ojos cuando trabajo ahora puedo
cambiar más tranquilo todo esto mientras
se genera ahorro en combustible
repuestos y filtros a las compañías que
adquirieron este producto una reflexión
final que quiero hacer es que en el
mundo existen miles de proyectos de
investigación que tienen por objetivo
mitigar el impacto ambiental pero muy
pocas veces sus resultados iban a
transferirse a la industria y peor aún
muy pocas veces estos resultados y hagan
las manos de quien realmente lo necesita
hace unos años fui consciente de que era
parte de un gran problema lo enfrenté y
deje de ser deje deje de hacerlo al
volver mi carro más ecológico y
eficiente quise llevar es este beneficio
al mundo y fracasé en camino con darío
formamos un gran equipo y nos dimos
cuenta que el problema era aún más
grande luego de años de investigación
puedo decir con orgullo que nuestras
manos tenemos un producto que puede
ayudar a miles
personas que al igual que yo en un
momento buscan tener un vehículo mucho
más ecológico eficiente y confiable una
tecnología que reduce las emisiones
significativamente y que estamos seguros
que un futuro próximo
ayudará a reducir problemas que afectan
el medio ambiente y la salud pública
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]